j'ai pas compris en fait comment ce
conseil scientifique est arrivé à
prendre le pouvoir sur la france pendant
un an pendant toute l'année 2020 et
c'est très flou en fait la façon dont il
a été nommé j'ai l'impression que j'ai
c'est qu'en fait il ya un homme jean
françois delfraissy qui a estimé qu'il
était l'homme de la situation et
finalement il a pris le pouvoir et même
emmanuel macron au début sur l'année
2020 finalement a pas vraiment garder le
contrôle de la situation et a fallu
attendre début 2000 21 pour qu'il décide
de reprendre le pouvoir donc c'est une
situation complètement folle où un homme
qui n'a aucun mandat finalement réuni
quelques amis dans un conseil
scientifique et décide que c'est lui qui
va décider comment vont vivre les
français de mars 2020 à janvier 2021
cette fois ils perdent des frais singtel
précis mais le vrai sujet du coi
et donc c'est qu'elle est qu'elles sont
les les décisions qu'ils ont prises qui
peuvent être en étant côte discutant
glace déjà les décisions déconfinement
aussi strictes qu'ils ont été décidés
c'est quand même quelque chose que
radieux est très discuté je rappelle que
premier confinement il a été décidé sur
quelques courbes qui nous venaient qui
nous venait d'angleterre et même le
deuxième confinement on se demande
pourquoi il y avait besoin d'être aussi
strictes ensuite il se tester tracé
isolé qui a jamais montré son efficacité
sur lequel on s'est complètement entêté
il ya eu ces attestations pour sortir à
moins d'un kilomètre voilà toutes ces
choses là finalement ont été décidées
sur un coin de table sans que ce soit
très solide et je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui auraient pu réfléchir sur ces
sujets là qui n'était pas le conseil
scientifique aurait été plus légitime
moi je vous ai suivis pendant toute la
pandémie sur les différentes chaînes et
j'ai l'impression qu'au début vous étiez
plutôt pro restricteurs etiassé elle a
remis sur le co vide et après on a
l'impression que ça se passait de
l'autre côté en disant voilà les
français sont assez libres qu'est ce qui
vous a fait basculer une bascule non
mais ça c'est quelque chose que
j'explique en fait j'ai été jugée
alarmiste en 2020 parce que j'ai
rapidement dit qu'ils allaient avoir un
deuxième vague est en fait les gens ne
voulaient pas y croire ces cdt des jours
heureux à des manuels macron ils vont
revenir imaginons ça risque de revenir
c'est que 5% de la population qui a été
infecté donc il ya aucune raison pour
que ça ne revienne pas assez
effectivement revenu et ensuite après il
ya eu ce deuxième confinement est on
arrivé en début 2000 21 où il ya eu
plein de gens qu'on commence à dire il
faut faire du zéro co vide du zéro covit
du zéro co vide sinon il ya des morts
pour rien et cette stratégie est folle
aujourd'hui on sait envoie en compte ce
que ça fait envoie en chine sans me en
train d'en sortir et là je suis passé du
côté des rats sur east parce que j'étais
contre en fait cette folie qui étaient
les héros comique qui était une théorie
extrémistes en fait qu'une théorie de
dire doit dès qu'il ya trois-quatre
qu'ovide on confine tout le périmètre
pendant deux trois semaines et on ne
supporte pas qu'il ait le moindre cas de
covin dans la population voilà et là je
suis passé du côté des draps sur iis
mais en fait c'est toujours pareil ça
dépend du référentiel rassure is par
rapport à une folie qui étaient les
locaux vides plutôt alarmiste par
rapport aux jours heureux et l'épidémie
ne reviendrait alors en page 44 vous
expliquer
non pas chez 44 vous expliquer votre
constat édifiant que vous avez établi
avec le médecin clément lazarus il n'y a
quasiment aucun malade de l'aco vide
chez les patients qui sont traités par
deux antidépresseurs clairement
identifiés par les quads de xanax et ça
alors c'est bon c'est pas là que le
docteur lazerus ce serait un autre mais
effectivement il ya des recherches qui
ont été faites en france et partout dans
le monde sur le fait qu'il y avait des
annexes et un clip ne salue bien rodée
et pénales accord n'est pas un
antidépresseur mais à certains
médicaments antidépresseurs
effectivement qui semblait faire
beaucoup moins de formes sévères de la
copie décès des travaux qui ont été
menés et c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas du
tout été porté par les groupes de
recherche français qu'on peut tout
cherché à porter des choses qui n'ont
pas fonctionné et en fait ce que j'ai
observé c'est quelque chose que je
savais déjà mais j'observe dans la crise
et que si vous n'êtes pas dans le sérail
si vous n'êtes pas dans les bons groupes
vous n'avez pas le droit d'avoir d'idées
et il faut venir de certains groupes
pour avoir des idées effectivement ces
chercheurs là ne peuvent pas porté leurs
recherches ne peuvent pas les développer
je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dommageable la façon dont ça fonctionne
vous raconter non plein de choses dans
l'île vous raconter aussi que vous
découvrez le jeu des plateaux télé c'est
vrai que vous en avez fait énormément
vous avez fait contre 1200 plateau
tennis ouais sans doute sans doute plus
je dirais que pendant deux ans j'ai dû
en faire quasiment un par jour il y
avait énormément d'actualité et puis
surtout j'avais l'impression que il
fallait parfois tenir un discours qui
étaient opposés parce que quelque part
on était un ou deux face à des dizaines
voire plus que des dizaines de médecins
et donc effectivement il fallait donner
de la part de voix parfois des
stratégies qui était anti 0 covin par
exemple vous dites enfin soyons clairs
je n'ai jamais sollicité une seule de
ces interventions je n'ai jamais
téléphoné à pascal praud à david pujadas
soit cyril hanouna pour quémander
quelques minutes de micros sous le nez
je m'appelais pourriez d'ailleurs vous
pouvez m'appeler ou avec grand plaisir
et chaque fois ce sont les équipes en
charge de la programmation qui m'ont
proposé de participer jamais l'inversé
aux confins complètement martin c'est
toujours nous qui l'avons invité lui la
voilà il devenait gentiment pour nous
expliquer parce que c'est vrai que
toutes les émissions de télévision à ce
moment-là demander des médecins et les
médecins au courant de ce qui se passait
sur leur plateau et nous c'est vrai
qu'on est bien voir martin et c'est
toujours nous qui l'avons sollicité j
avais marre qu'on nous a dit et ce que
je peux venir ce soir pour parler de 6
ou pour parler de ça ça n'est jamais
arrivé dans notre émission vous avez
fait donc plus de 1200 plateau télé en
deux ans vous dit j'assume parfaitement
d'avoir participé à l'émission qu'anime
syrie là d'un choix qui m'a été parfois
reprocher par certains de mes amis
notamment mais que je ne regrette pas un
instant comme jour ne regrette aucune
des minutes passées sur le plateau de
david pujadas sur lci bah pour moi
c'était un moment extrêmement important
parce que déjà chaque émission à son
public et je moi j'ai toujours pensé que
la jeunesse avait été maltraité pendant
cette crise et vous êtes une des
émissions qui s'adresse à la jeunesse
donc pour moi c'était une des émissions
les plus importantes qu'il fallait faire
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une espèce de
snobisme intellectuel à chaque fois que
vous allez chez cyril hanouna on vous
dit mais pourquoi tu vas là-bas tu
décris des milices ta parole mais ma
parole elle est crédible parce que je
dis sur c'est ma part j'ai donc je viens
ici je m'adresse à un public et je
l'assumé complètement c'était une des
émissions que je préférais faire entrer
ya beaucoup de donneurs de leçons que
personne n'entend qui font trois tweets
et qui surtout été deux fois et qu'ils y
voilà qu'ils disent un petit peu cliquer
c'est un petit peu d'influencé les uns
et les autres si vous avez des donneurs
de leçons aussi sur le plateau
non c'est mc kee qui vous a gêné les
missions au quotidien moi je vais pas du
tout aimé je suis très transparent sur
ce qui s'est passé j'ai les équipes de
quotidiens qui m'appelle et me dit
monsieur blachier on veut passer une
journée à vous suivre toute la journée
jeudi il en est hors de question vous
allez pas me suivre avec la caméra sur
l'épaule toute la journée si vous voulez
venez passer deux heures au bureau jeudi
à la journaliste judith mais vous je
vous préviens c'est un bureau
d'épidémiologie donc vous allez voir des
gens derrière les ordinateurs pas de
problème monsieur blaché en vient jeudi
en plus j'ai une réunion donc pendant
une heure vous allez tourner dans les
bureaux mais moi je serai pas disponible
très bien très bien on vient on vient on
vient force la main ils viennent j'ouvre
la porte et elle caméraman qui me filme
et la journaliste qui rentrent et qu'il
dit mais où sont les malades où sont les
malades joué aucun malade
gimont super merci c'était très bien
donc je discute un petit peu je leur
explique ce qu'on fait ils ont
évidemment rien garder je le redis je
dois faire mon col maintenant je vais
m'isoler une heure à vous faites comme
chez vous je suis très sympa quoi et
donc qu'ils vont voir chaque mes
salariés et 10 est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire des choses du mal en gros de
votre chef donc est-ce qu'il est là tous
les jours est ce qu'il fait exprès
d'aller sur les placements c'était la
même chose avec moi
et donc en fait à la fin ils font un
truc ultra montée en disant que je dis
n'importe quoi et j'ai trouvé un procédé
assez les seuls à avoir fait ça c'est à
dire que les autres son honnêteté
vouloir dire quelque chose ils prennent
en considération ce que 8e en fait c'est
c'est du cash investigations mais en
ultra déformé quoi c'est vraiment c'est
absolument pas honnête intellectuelle il
ya une question de béatrice schönberg
bonjour martin d'abord je voudrais vous
dire que j'adore votre femme
je suis tout à fait sur sa ligne et
voulais vous poser une question de temps
en temps vous aviez des interventions
qui était assez tranchés par exemple de
gérer le coït comme on gère la grippe et
puis l'intervention d'après c'était
beaucoup plus mesuré je voulais savoir
si vous receviez dépression de quelqu'un
ou si vous étiez recadrer de temps en
temps quand vous intervenez
de façon très tranché plus dans ma
direction voilà n'ont jamais reçu aucune
pression ni de la part d'une rédaction
ni de la part de n'importe quel
gouvernement politique et comme je suis
patron de ma propre entreprise c'est moi
qui décide et finalement c'est peut-être
avec les équipes qu'on ait le plus de
discussions mais n'ont aucune pression
j'étais totalement libre voilà équilibre
alors vous avez reçu des menaces de mort
aussi quand après avoir confronté didier
raoult professeurs ou dans les jours qui
suivent je reçois des lettres de menaces
de mort au bureau comme à mon domicile
où les messages d'insultés s'empilent le
premier l'enfer et la mère de mes trois
enfants mon ex épouse est contrainte de
demander le changement de son numéro de
téléphone harcelée jour et nuit par des
appels violents ouais c'est tout à fait
vrai ça a été assez violent en
particulier effectivement dans cette
phase de 2020 où il y avait un phénomène
out qui était qui était incroyable je
crois que se rend même pas compte en
fait ce que c'est sur le phénomène raout
et j'avais des menaces de mort quasiment
quotidiennes par courrier par téléphone
effectivement il appelait la nuisance
ulta et disaient qu'ils allaient nous
tuer qu'ils allaient nous attendre en
bas de chez nous donc c'était non
c'était assez violent et après ça c'est
complètement calmés à partir de 2021 il
ya plus ce phénomène mais il ya vraiment
une espèce de folie à l'été 2020 où
c'était c'est assez violent mardi
souvent venu nous voir aussi un ou en
fait time we see qui nous avons la même
bien aussi un jour on fera un plateau
avec vous et et qui dira voilà alors et
si oui alors vous avez rencontré
brigitte macron raconté avoir été invité
à l'élysée grâce à votre ami votre ami
et gérald direct on embrasse pour
rencontrer la première dame autour d'un
déjeuner conduit dans un salon doré la
patiente une dizaine de minutes avant
d'être chaleureusement accueilli par
brigitte mcmahon et gentille elle est
adorable avec quelqu'un et c'est
carrément un contact extrêmement facile
sans faire de politique je vous jure je
les dis toujours c'est vraiment c'est
vrai moi je les ai vus encore dernière
fois elle qui bonjour à tout le monde
est-ce pas la tête celle qui vient vers
les gens celle qui vient parle à tout le
monde et si vraiment les l incroyable
tout à fait vous êtes vous êtes
complètement envoûté en fait c'est
exactement en contact dans l'humain en
fait est qu'ils sont qui sont très très
bien les choses et donc j'étais très
content de la rencontre et ce qu'elle me
disait me semblait y perd beaucoup de
bon sens et beaucoup de curiosité en
fait elle a envie d'aller envie de
savoir pourquoi vous l'avez rencontré là
bas c'est gérald effectivement qui me
dit ça l'intéresserait beaucoup de te
rencontrer c'était à l'époque en fait
j'étais à peu près le seul anti zéro co
vide et a cité la ligne que son mari
avait choisi et donc je pense que les
tigres et de tous ces efforts que je
faisais pour montrer que ce n'était pas
une mauvaise stratégie parce que c'est
vrai que pendant six mois c'est ce que
j'appelle les six mois héroïque des
manuels macron il a été seul contre tous
et c'est vrai qu'il a tenus il y en
avait pas un pour dire qu' il ne s'était
pas un criminel et ont tué pas des gens
vous a senti un moment avec emmanuel
macron puis plus avec emmanuel macron
vous a senti un peu voilà ma madeleine
de conduire n'est pas dessus emmanuel
macron et donc sur les six premiers mois
de 2010 21 j'étais emmanuel macron à
100% et c'est vrai que sur la fin quand
il a commencé à aller sur son pass
vaccinale et qu' il a insisté dans ses
stratégies et qu il était sur une
stratégie de gonfler les chiffres de
vaccination en vaccinant les jeunes
alors que moi je pensais qu'il fallait
vacciner 100% des populations
vulnérables j'étais plus sur sa ligne et
donc effectivement j'étais pas je pense
qu'il a fait une erreur d'ailleurs avec
le pass vaccinale il semblait sans doute
sans doute rendu compte mais j'ai jamais
cherché de particulièrement ligne avec
lui oui j'ai bien dit oui alors vous
êtes une star des plateaux télé vous
êtes brillant le livre c'est un livre
événement vous êtes reçus à la à
l'elysée qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ce qui explique que des médecins stars
comme vous ont un peu oublié le coeur de
cible d'un médecin qui est de soigner
des patients c'est moi je suis le maître
500 patients fait déjà donc c est ce que
ce n'est pas un problème ban moi je suis
bien à lille que c'est moins un problème
c'est mon métier en fait je suis médecin
de santé publique donc je travaille sur
la santé des populations locales là
dessus j'ai zéro complexe et honnêtement
je suis toujours resté sur ma ligne
d'ailleurs je suis une star des plateaux
télé mais sans doute qui va être plus
tard deux plateaux télé dans les boxes
et non mais c'était tout le monde
une espèce de mission jeux d'eau et
parce que j'avais quelque chose à dire
martin puisque vous dites aussi aux gens
qui disent que vous êtes le médecin qui
murmurait à l'oreille des manuels macron
je pense clairement
j'ai envoyé un certain nombre de notes
et je vous savez les choses se passent
très différemment de ce que les gens
imaginent c'est à dire que ce que vous
dites sur les plateaux télé finalement
voulu adresser à des gens et je connais
un tout petit peu le monde politique ce
qui est dit sur les plateaux compte et
compte énormément et compte en
particulier quand vous êtes dans une
forte période d'incertitudes puisque on
est dans une démocratie et donc
l'opinion bouge en permanence et
l'opinion détermine un petit peu aussi
la décision publique donc je pense que
ce qui est dit sur les plateaux
finalement est souvent plus important
que ce qui va être envoyée dans des
notes qui sont très rarement lu au
général c'est le dernier conseiller qui
a vu l'exécutif qui a raison alors
depuis quelques jours les chiffres covit
semble remonter et certains craignent
une sixième vague ce sera à cause d'un
variant du variant au micron bea point
de on dirait une orientation pour un
nouveau bail c est ce que c'est c'est
vrai cette affaire on peut avoir une
sixième bague puisque même même olivier
ferrand a alerté a dit attention achtung
achtung est ce qu'on peut avoir les
contaminations qui remonte donc faire
une sixième vague de contaminations oui
c'est un peu la direction que ça prend
c'est dire que ça prend en angleterre
qui a toujours un petit peu d'avancé est
en train de le suivre est-ce que c'est
grave non parce qu'aujourd'hui les virus
qui circule avec la vaccination et
l'immunité naturelle qu'on a acquis
c'est l'équivalent de la grippe c'est ce
que disent les anglais donc s'il faut
faire un branle bas de combat à chaque
fois qu'il ya une vague de grippe donc
je pense qu'on surveillait j'ai un petit
peu mais j'espère j'ai l'impression que
c'est la direction comprend qu'on va
rester sur sa stratégie de revenir dans
un an un mode de vie normale et ne plus
être dans la course et que c'est fini
les confinements les vallées
un truc les bars fermés des restaurants
fermés ni couvre feu les couvreurs je
pense que les confinements les
couvre-feux oui je pense que c'est fini
ça parce que ça c'était un aîné après
les rappels vaccinaux pour une partie de
la population on peut pas s'engager là
dessus parce qu'on a encore par
l'incertitude sur la durée de cette
immunité d'accord oui mais est-ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui que dès le début
c'était une grosse grippe le kobinan ou
alors d'accord mais c'est un peu plus
dur au début mais il ya des courbes et
c'est intéressant qui sont montrés au
début on était quasiment à 20 fois la
grippe en taux de mortalité donc ça
n'avait rien à voir rien mais là
effectivement depuis l'arrivée de micros
on était sûr de vivre qu'est ce qu'on a
sur réagi et cette vague ou micron oui
très probablement donc maintenant est
vraiment passé sur autre chose et on est
plutôt quelque chose de l'ordre de la
grippe fiction mais ce n'est pas griot
de gérald ou non mais d'un côté vous
dites y'a les alarmistes de l'autre côté
les rassure east d'un côté il ya ceux
qui ont fait 0 comme idée l'autre et
d'autres qui ont dit non mais finalement
c'est rien on laisse on laisse faire en
fait quel est le pays qui a fait
vraiment beaucoup mieux que nous est ce
qu'il ya un pays qui a fait vraiment
beaucoup mieux que m'ont finalement bah
moi quand vous parlez que des gens qui
voyagent beaucoup à l'international ils
vous disent qu'il ya peu de pays qu'on
était aussi stricte que la france c'est
à dire que les confinements tels que
nous on l'a connu ou levier signer un
papier pour aller à plus 500 mètres de
votre domicile c'est quelque chose qui
n'existait nulle part ailleurs au monde
et l'autre chose c'est que la peur du
coc vive a été je pense l'une des plus
importantes au monde sait que l'anxiété
qu on la transmet à la population ça a
été en france d'érable en france en
france et quand vous parler avec des
gens et qui font du business et qui vont
par exemple en scandinavie même en
allemagne en italie et au bouddhisme et
la trouille du coc vide c'est quelque
chose de français c'est à dire qu'il n'y
avait pas ces tagueurs n'avait pas de
fous peur panique dans les autres pays
et je pense que ça ça joue aussi avec
tout ça oui mais par exemple vous allez
on scande ebola la suède ça fait un an
et demi que les gens vivent normalement
sur l anglais regardez-la fait quasiment
un an que les gens vivent ça c'est
normalement en france les gens sont
restés ils ont été marqués bah oui mais
la scandinavie italie ils ont été
surtout marquée par le premier
traumatisme médias passage cette
continuité de peur comme ça en
permanence pendant deux ans la
scandinavie et écoulent les derniers
essais allaient de l'acte beaucoup de
candidats est-ce qu'il fallait vacciner
bah bien sûr il fallait l'accord et les
solex met en revanche en revanche sur la
vague ou micron est ce qu'on aura
nécessairement besoin de faire un
booster chez les moins de 60 ans la
réponse est non et on ne savait pas à
l'époque cette décision était prise
potel
paraissent compliquées dans la vie
quotidienne des gens parce que beaucoup
la reçoivent des notifications comme
quoi le pass va expirer et vous devez
prendre un rendez vous pour faire un
énième rappel il faut continuer à faire
ça vous pensez qu'il faut abandonner
tout ça
pour lui ça concerne pas non mais non ça
concerne des défis énormes et si vous
voulez mon avis oui scientifique si vous
avez plus de 50 ans allez faire votre
appel si vous avez moins de 50 ans
allait le faire si vous êtes vous voulez
mettre ceinture et bretelles mais c'est
pas la chose la plus importante du monde
vous aurez sans doute d'autres problèmes
plus importants que ça dans la vie
m